i
i place him as one of the premier
theoretical physicists
probably of all time is he's up there
he's with gail mann he's with feynman
he's with hawking he's incredible
um i think there's a whole generation of
us uh physicists working today
for whom weinberg is is just well
you know just just a legend just just
the the absolute legend i know of um
a few guys i know who talked about you
know whenever whenever
they would literally bow to weinberg if
they heard him speak right so
this is this is a guy who isn't just a
noble or it he's a
noble laureate absolute legend of
physics
he was the one we looked up to his work
which led to the standard model
of particle physics has stood the test
of time
one of the problems we have at the large
adron collider is we can't see
deviations from what he predicted
it's just so so superb
and and so robust in terms of impact of
what he's achieved in terms of you know
impact on advancing physics but also
his textbooks and and those sorts of
things that have taught us all
how to understand physics i mean any
physics i actually
would claim to understand and that might
be quite limited
i would say i'll be thanks to weinberg
and and actually
following his message and and what he
taught us about physics
absolute legend he wrote a paper called
a model
of the leptons you know leptons are
particles like the electron
it's a two and a half page paper
and he in it he he unified
the force of electromagnetism and the
weak force
we think of four forces of nature really
right we think of gravity
we think of the strong force which binds
the nucleus together
we know the weak force which you know
why the sun burns why we're alive
and we know of electromagnetism and one
of the goals of
theoretical physics and actually
weinberg was the premier person
in pushing for this goal this
reductionist idea was
maybe these four forces as you go to
higher and higher energies
can be described by a more unified
approach maybe there's an
underlying mathematical description
which gives you all of them
and they only begin to manifest
themselves as the universe
cools down and expands and we know of an
example right
electromagnetism we know that we have
electricity
and we have magnetism we know that if we
push a bar magnet through a coil of wire
it will produce a current
so the magnetic field is affecting the
electric field
we know that if we change the electric
field we'll produce a magnetic field
and maxwell showed actually that we
could think of them as the same
effectively
and what weinberg did in this amazing
paper are then
independently was done by salam and by
glacial
was he demonstrated that you could unify
the weak force
the weak interactions with
electromagnetism now people have been
trying to do this
this previously and in particular you
know people like
sheldon glashoff who was actually he was
actually a high school
uh friend of of weinberg they went to
the same school they both won nobel
prizes and they went to the same school
how much is that and they won in the
same year as well okay glashow would
realize that you know if you
if you want to you've got
electromagnetism you've got the weak
force the electro electromagnetism
contained the photon
the weak force believed to contain these
w bosons
uh one which was positively charged one
which was negatively charged
he wanted to bring them all together and
he realized that that just didn't seem
to balance there needed to be
another neutral sort of
something like the photon but another
one something else
which is the z boson which was
associated with the weak force so there
were these things there were these
all these force carriers these four
force carriers and they had to be put
together
in a consistent theory now why did
people believe they should be put
together was
was because you know electromagnetism
and weak force they
seem to be dancing in the same bottle
room in some respects
you have you have sort of for example
the electromagnetic force which is
moving charges around
and the weak force which is somehow
changing electro electric charges
you can have processes that involve the
weak force where the electric charge
changes
changes so it seemed like they were all
dancing in the same ballroom and it sort
of
it was natural to try to bring it
together glacial said well this is
probably what you need you probably need
this photon going along with these
two w bosons which are charged and but
there should also be this
this zed boson which should be neutral
but he couldn't quite figure out how to
put it all together in a consistent way
what wimbegg did was he took those
papers from 1964
that uh people had been using to you
know we now talk about with the higgs
mechanism and all the you know the
discovery of the higgs
weinberg took those papers and took the
mechanism they had for
for giving mass to some of these these
these bosons
and he incorporated it into this the
ideas of glacier and
and people like that in terms of
bringing these two forces together and
he created this consistent theory
and what i particularly like about it
was that he wasn't actually thinking
about this initially he was thinking
about the quarks he was thinking about
the strong force
and in his calculations he was finding
that it was predicting a massless
particle
which was the pa the pion was massless
but he knew the pion wasn't massless
so it wasn't working there and
at that time of his life he was he had
young children he was out looking after
them quite often because his wife was
working as well
and when he was out he was thinking
about what's going on and you realized
actually maybe
i could apply this formalism to
the weak interactions and and
electromagnetism because we know the
photon
is massless he had these four sort of
force carriers the photon and the three
carriers of the weak force he needed to
make three of them heavy
and so he realizes that meant that the
higgs particle that he had to introduce
into the game to make them heavy
had to have basically had to be able to
give three degrees of freedom to the
three
heavy bosons and then there would be one
degree of freedom left over which would
be the higgs that we see
and it's exactly the physics that we see
so this new theory which was unifying
the
the weak interactions and the
electromagnetism predicted the existence
of what we call
weak neutral currents or the zed
particle
it's called which was it was the
initiator of an interaction between if
you had an electron and a neutrino and
this scatter so incomes and electron
incomes and neutrino and the scatter
the the mediator which allows for that
scattering was that it was this neutral
current
which included the zed particle and it
was a prediction in this two and a half
page paper
beautiful beautiful paper and he didn't
really believe
it he knew it was good but he didn't
really believe that it was
he didn't really think it's going to be
a description of nature
and this is really interesting because
he didn't know at that time whether this
theory which we call the electroweak
theory
was what we call renormalizable what
does that mean
renormalizable means that you can take
all the infinities which often occur in
quantum
mechanics in quantum field theory and
properly absorb them into physical
quantities
so that you end up with a predictive
theory if you have something that gives
you an infinity and you don't know what
to do with it then how do you
know how to believe any of the finite
results renormalization is the technique
which allows you to
properly absorb them that's called the
regularization bit
and then make a prediction for a finite
quantity he didn't know
if the theory was renormalizable and it
wasn't and so this
this model got very little attention if
i remember right it only had for about
the first two or three years
three or four citations it now has over
eleven and a half thousand by the way
three or four citations then in 1971
tooft and veltman showed in their own
nobel prize winning work
that this was a renormalizable theory
you could absorb these infinities
and wow took off a year later
they found that the at cern they found
the existence of these neutral currents
during the first experiment 500 000
photographs were taken
and the z particle emerged and that's
what was measured
inside this chamber back in 1973.
so this is a big this is this is a piece
of history it really is a piece of
history this
this the experiment that went on in this
machine actually won uh glashoff
weinberg and salam the nobel prize in
1979 what happened in this they've got a
lot to thank
thank this machine for yeah i mean i
think the way i've seen this put really
nicely in the last few days you know
sort of
and i think it's nice to put it in this
context you know isaac newton
sort of he sort of brought together sort
of terrestrial gravity and celestial
gravity you know
he brought those two together and merged
them into one maxwell
you know he brought together electricity
and magnetism made them into into into
one unified
theory and weinberg did the same thing
he took electromagnetism in the weak
theory and he combined them into one
theory which was electroweak theory
that was weinberg's legacy to to bring
these two theories together and you just
look at the other names i mentioned and
you really see the context of the
quality we're talking about he also in
in that paper by the way the one that
the two and a half page paper he kind of
introduced the higgs
higgs of course had done his work in
1966
what what a time this was in the early
64 65 66
so there was higgs there was brought an
angler and there was kibble and
collaborators and they'd all postulated
this particle which became known as the
higgs
but what weinberg actually did was
weinberg actually placed it in the
context of the electro weak theory he
said it must be here and when it is here
it will give me these interactions
and so in some sense the discovery of
the higgs that this at the lhc i think
you could say his discovery of the
weinberg
higgs that he postulated would be there
i i would say
weinberg what do you have this uncanny
knack of sort of unpicking
the the details of any any given
scenario in physics
you know whether you're talking about
cosmology whether you're talking about
general relativity whether you're
talking about quantum mechanics whether
you're talking about quantum field
theory
whatever any branch of physics weinberg
had this ability just to
basically almost forget what everybody
else had told him about it
and look at it on his terms so we'd look
at this branch of physics let's say
quantum mechanics for the sake of
argument he'd look at it on his terms
and then unpick it in his way
the coupling constant appears in the
lagrangian multiplying some kind of
operator
and then somehow because of his superb
insight obviously
he was able to sort of then understand
it more deeply than perhaps
others had and at the same time he was
able to convey that understanding
to the rest of us you know as much as we
could understand you know sort of
the level of weinberg things but but it
you know i think that's what it was i
think was his ability just to
to stand back and say i'm going to look
at this on my terms and then when he did
that
you know things just opened up for him
you said you sort of talk about how this
famous paper was two and a half pages
and this little smile comes across your
face
why is that what's special about the
fact it was two and a half pages i think
it shows
this was someone who was so in charge of
what he was doing
that he knew the essence of what you
needed to say he knew exactly what
needed to be said
and he knew exactly how to say it and
the eloquence of it is like reading a
beautiful novel i mean when
in heinz i think if i was reading in the
early 60s i was 67 i'd have been totally
flummoxed by it
but in hindsight having you know you you
teach courses on it you attend courses
on it you go to lectures on this subject
you become familiar with the terminology
and what it is
to see it written as the initial kind of
breakthrough paper is just
staggering and i think that's why
smiling at the two and a half page
and the fact you know i'm currently
writing a 40-page paper and i think well
what what what impact is that going to
have on the world
you know you you go through his book on
quantum field theory
and and or you know or general
relativity and things are just
put in in such a in a clear way
and and i said i i think he is i think
he's taught a generation
and how to think like a physicist i
think i think that's what it is he's
taught us how to how to think like a
physicist now
i'm certain that many many of us fall
short we don't we're nowhere near
weinberg's level
but but what we do right i think we do
right most was thanks to the wayne
weinberg has taught us to think
i think he really has taught a
generation of physicists how to think
properly so i started my phd in 1982 in
newcastle and for the first few months
anyone doing a phd knows yes
you're scrabbling in the dark you you
might be given a project to do
and i did it and i'd written a paper and
and that was great i had a lovely start
and but it wasn't what i wanted to
really do i didn't know what i really
wanted to do
and then i went to this meeting at the
royal society which weinberg had
organized
and it was a meeting on the fundamental
constants it's
i think it's turned into quite a famous
meeting because i was
no not because i was there but um but he
was there he was there
hawking was there it is the meeting
where and i was at the talk where
hawking said that n equals eight super
gravity is probably going to be the
theory of everything
we've just got a few things to wrap up
and by the turn of the century we'll
have done it
and we're still searching for it but
weinberg came on and gave a talk
and i just sat there and i thought wow
wow wow and he was talking about some
work he did with
another brilliant physicist or
mathematician really my mathematical
office is called philip candelas who's
raous professor at
mathematics at oxford they'd work
together on a theory
called klutzy klein theory that is the
idea that the universe is made up of
extra dimensions
and why don't we see them well all the
extra dimensions are in a small in a
sphere
and what he what they said was that the
forces that we see
electromagnetism the strong force and
the weak force are manifestations of
this
compact dimensions and i thought this
was so beautiful because you could have
a theory here which was this extra
dimensional theory which is pure
gravity but when you sort of take out
your four dimensions of space time that
we live in
and you reinterpret these extra
dimensions you reinterpret them as the
forces of nature and and
and i thought i want to do this this is
what i want to do i was lucky because a
a a guy came to newcastle at the time
called the
david tomes and he was working in this
field
and so we got working together and that
was my whole phd and then
at the end of my phd so my phd is on
quantum
collusion quantum corrections includes a
clan cosmologist because of a talk by
weimar yeah
completely completely because of this
talk weinberg didn't write any more
papers on this as far as i could tell i
think he had no interest
he he he just he just moved on to
something else
maybe he wrote one or two more but it
wasn't i looked them up the other day i
couldn't find
anymore but you you pioneered my
research
and then from there as i came to the end
of my phd
i thought well what what i'd like to do
a postdoc and i wrote to him
um and i said would they if i can get a
fellowship could i come
to austin texas where you are and join
your group
and to my amazement you're up i said
yeah sure i was very short
yeah sure come along less than two and a
half percent it was less than two and a
half pages
so i went to the for what known as the
scrc interviews it's
what would now you'd think of as stfc
but at the time science and engineering
research council
and i got the fellowship and i was all
geared up to go
and the pound completely crashed the
pound went
from something like 1.70 down to a
dollar
and i was being paid in pounds and so my
my whole fellowship was worth about 10
000 pounds i made inquiries
it would have cost me 10 000 pounds just
to rent a property
and so i was lucky i got so instead of
working with um
weinberg i ended up working with kibble
because
imperial also offered me a position and
i took the fellowship
to imperial where i ended up working
with some people so it was fine i mean
i i did i did i did okay in the end
thanks to
thanks to uh imperial but i was gonna go
to i i did i did tell weinberg this i
told him i i met him
um weinberg had a lot of respect for
kibble
and and when tom kibble who you might
remember didn't get the nobel prize
with a video imperial invited weinberg
to give the main
talk at its birth 80th birthday
celebration for tom kibble and weinberg
came in
and he gave this staggering talk no
notes no nothing just stood there for an
hour
and afterwards we went for dinner and um
so i told him that story and you know
after he'd cry after he'd stop crying
he was okay about it
he could have worked and what was he
like to talk to was he know
he was it was great it was quite direct
you know
it didn't it there were so many
people wanting to just say hello to him
it was but he was very polite and
what do you mean by director then well
he just said um sorry to hear that
then we moved on it was you know there
was
not much small chat in between now
we people talk about for example the
theory of everything well
i suppose you could argue that that
maxwell's bringing together electricity
and magnetism was the first step on that
and the second step was weinberg
bringing electromagnetism and the weak
force together to make electro weak
theory
so you now got building up these ideas
to sort of bring all of physics together
into a theory of everything which is not
completed yet
hopefully i think something like string
theory probably a good candidate for for
achieving that
but it's kind of you see what what what
what weinberg was starting to build
there really the passage towards the
theory of everything i would say
what should we think about these people
dying i mean obviously
people get old and they die yeah but
like what does it mean that some of
these you know a lot of these really big
names in physics are dying now is that
just like does that mean anything or
i think there i think it's a sign that
there's a whole generation of
real superstars and it's an
interesting question is that have we got
you know
people to replace them i don't think we
have at the moment i mean we've got some
brilliant people but they're not there's
one or two i mean there's a
there's the wittons and maybe maldocinas
out there who
have had a fantastic impact but
it's certainly the case that you know
the likes of feynman and gel man
and hawking with hawking evaporation and
and and weinberg
you know with his model of the leptons
they were making predictions for things
that you can go looking for of course
hawking of operations very
no one's seen that but the idea of you
know singularity theorems of
penrose and company um i'm not sure we
we we have that at the moment right the
theoretical
position we're in it's it's got much
more difficult
in many ways the calculations that can
be done
have been done and and we're left with
things trying to
figure out where to go from there i
think the subjects in quite an
interesting stage of you know where do
we go from
here and that's one of the big debates
that's going on should there be a new
super collider right to to go looking
for the higgs or
go looking for super symmetry the things
that have been put forward
we don't know what the dark matter is we
don't know what the dark energy
is we don't know where the supersymmetry
is out there
we still don't understand why the
particles have the masses that they've
got
and we don't have any
decent explanation for these so i don't
think we could say we have the people
who have made those fundamental
predictions like
i would say weinberg did and feynman did
are you jealous of people like stephen
weinberg it's the point being jealous
it's like they're jealous and messy
you know you just they're just they're
just there right they're just they're
just better
right you know he's blessed and he's
brilliant
and you know i'm just glad that the
world of physics
has people like that because they help
us advance so much
and also and i think for those of us
that sort of working
you know these levels below you know
they do give us these nuggets of ideas
that we can play with okay we're never
going to do the wonderful things that
they did but but they give us these
nuggets of ideas and they help us
understand at least
um so yeah no the wirings of the world
are wonderful
back in 1973. so this is a big this is
this is a piece of history is it it
really is a piece of history this this
the experiment that went on
in this machine actually won uh glashoff
weinberg and salam the nobel prize in
1979 what happened in here they've got a
lot to thank
thank this machine for